dans cet immeuble tout neuf de jeunes
adultes trisomiques et déficients
intellectuels vivent seuls leurs parents
leur rendent souvent visite
mais après leur journée de travail ou de
cours ils rentrent chez eux maintenant
[Musique]
sur le balcon de cloud et on devine déjà
qu'il y aura du bleu dans son petit
studio cependant l'iphone ça fait un
changement dans notre ville
etienne a choisi de décorer son
appartement avec une touche weston et
marque souligne les origines maritime de
sa famille avec les tables ou qu'ils
paient 10 jours marque était chez nous à
la maison chez toi ici
est ce que tu aimes ça dans l'immeuble
de trois étages de l'appart à moi il y a
dix studios comptent 1 pour la résidente
surveillante et une grande salle commune
où la plupart d'entre eux mangent tous
les soirs cet organisme sans but
lucratif est né de l'initiative de
quelques parents et s'est concrétisée à
la mi juin avec l'arrivée des locataires
le moment où on a créé le
la papa mois l'organisme on est dans la
sixième année d'existence de l'organisme
donc c'est long comment on peut faire un
sort que veille leur liberté leur
autonomie tout en étant dans un milieu
sécuritaire
quelle transformation peut pas toujours
les athlètes dernière minute une
éducatrice spécialisée viendra deux fois
par semaine et gardera un lien avec la
coordonnatrice de l'organisme
si elle essaie de saint-hubert
accompagne les nouveaux locataires pour
adapter les lieux à leurs besoins dans
hawx avions polir puis on y voit par
code de couleurs puis faut leur donner
le plus d'un indice possible des projets
comme seul nous c'est ça le fun on en a
pas beaucoup c'est les parents qui ont
participé parce que au niveau de nos
ressources d'hébergement c'est pas le
formule non fonction que ce par famille
d'accueil
c'était important de bien faire du z
mémoire pour qu'ils oublient avant de
sortir de leur logement au lion glee la
construction a été financée par le
programme accès logis
c'est un projet de plus d'un million et
demi de dollars sans compter les
services a pour moteur ont subi entre
amis et nouvelle famille c'est
l'anniversaire des tiers
à moi ça chante grande inquiétude que
dans vieillissante et qui soit ceux là
je me dis c'est le fort miettes avec des
jeunes de son âge ils sont hyper occuper
c'est beau de voir c'est une nouvelle
fera crie on tournait pas une pleureuse
on aime beaucoup ses parents veulent
maintenant partager leurs démarches avec
d'autres qui voudrait s'inspirer de ce
modèle qui donne un appart à moi à des
jeunes qui n'en espéraient pas de temps
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
longueuil
[Musique]